-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
After it was announced
that Elon Musk
purchased Twitter this week,
Tesla stock fell by 11%.
Well, he wouldn't be
the first person
to get distracted from his job
by Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Congressman
Madison Cawthorn
was reportedly cited yesterday
at a North Carolina airport
because he had
a 9-millimeter handgun.
Just cited?!
[ Laughter ]
I bring a Poland Spring bottle
through security
and, suddenly,
I'm on a no-fly list.
[ Laughter ]
Madison Cawthorn brings a gun
and they're like,
"You're going to to have
to put the safety on
'til we get in the air."
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci
has reportedly pulled out
of Saturday's White House
Correspondents Dinner,
due to concerns
over the coronavirus.
I don't blame the guy.
He's 81.
I'm not even 50, and I still
only travel by Zorb.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
yesterday presented
his first city budget,
of $99.7 billion,
which means we're getting
[ Singsong ]
one new F Train!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Brand-new. Oh, somebody already
took a dump in it.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden announced today
that Trevor Reed,
a former Marine who had been
detained in Russia since 2019,
has been released,
as part of a prisoner swap
and it was a win-win
'cause, for some reason,
they wanted Weinstein.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ]
Want you to produce
movies for us.
[ Laughter ]
Vladimir wants to star
in his own
"Shakespeare in Love."
[ Laughter ]
The New York City Council
is currently considering a cut
to the local hotel tax,
in order to boost tourism,
because only in New York can you
pay 500 bucks to stay in a room
where you can flush the toilet
from the bed.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Director Justin Lin
announced yesterday
that he decided to leave
the movie "Fast X,"
just a few days
after production started.
So they're going to go
with Wes Anderson.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Justin Lin
announced yesterday
that he decided to leave
the movie "Fast X,"
reportedly due
to creative differences.
He wanted the movie
to be creative,
and no one else did.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
actress Megan Fox said
that she and her fiancé,
Machine Gun Kelly,
occasionally drink a few drops
of each other's blood,
for "ritual purposes only."
You know what?
These guys are a perfect couple,
because I look at them
and I cannot guess
whose idea that was.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know how, sometimes you'll
see a couple jogging in the park
and you'll say, "Oh,
she dragged his ass out there,"
or, "This was clearly his idea.
She's jogging in jeans."
[ Laughter ]
Not here.
Either one of these two
could've paused "Dateline"
and turned to the other one
and said,
"We should drink
each other's blood."
[ Laughter ]
Perfect match.
I have no notes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
singer Harry Styles will be
on the June cover of the
magazine Better Homes & Gardens.
And this is cool --
Martha Stewart
is on Tiger Beat.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue.
Tiger Beat.
[ Cheering and applause ]